another one of your most impressive
victories was the second fight with Dan
Henderson cuz you got hit with some
[ __ ] no yeah arms in that fight but
you refused to go out yeah you refused
to be stomped in that fight yeah you
know I mean that was a that was a
display of willpower in a lot of ways
because I remember watching those those
big shots from Henderson land and I mean
they were on the edge you think you were
on the edge going out oh for sure
absolutely I mean I remember he hit me I
went down he was swarming on me hit me
with some elbows but I remember I was
always fine but I was like holy [ __ ]
that was what hit me there and then I
managed to get myself back to my feet
and blood point I'm a face and whatnot
of course second rounds the same thing
happened and he had two big moments in
the fight two big shots but they were
big moments but you know when a
25-minute fire by London two shots you
know but they were big shots fair play
to him but you know I refused to quit
there because you know obviously going
into that fight I talked about the [ __ ]
like always you know and you can lie to
everybody you can lie to the media you
can lie to the press you can lie to your
family lighty coaches it's not
necessarily lies but you can use bravado
and this and that we can't lie to
yourself you know when you're let him
bed at night and your heads on the
cushion you know some [ __ ] yourself
you know and day of the fight because
the fire was at 6:00 in the morning
there the fire I'm letting my bed
trainer just have a nap because he was
going to be a long night obviously and I
couldn't sleep and all I was thinking
human nature last time I stepped into an
octagon with this guy I was [ __ ] out
cold for a long time my brain was
scrambled eggs for a long time after
that fight and as I say you can lie to
everybody else but now the fight was
getting close and it's in my hometown
and it's my first title defense and all
this I'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] I know I'm
better than this guy but [ __ ] last time
last time didn't end well so I was
getting a little worked up and I
remember I was at the arena and I was
kind of you know being a little edgy a
little snappy with people and there's
not need for it and then I just stopped
so I started laughing and Parrilla said
was way laughing I said well
what's the worst that can happen if I
lose what's the word I'm gonna lose a
fight it's happened before so why am i
stressing myself out of it I just
started laughing and after that was fine
but yeah yeah though it was a I
definitely had a saw face the next day
after that one for sure yeah but you you
know you got through the fire yeah no I
did and I felt great the only problem
was in the fifth round because this
cheekbone swung it was on my good side
he shied the cheekbone on my good side
and it swelled up so much I could hardly
see a tie this size folks as well so in
the fifth round I'm like trying to like
get certain angle where I could even see
the guy you know what I mean it was it
was a nightmare you know but ya got the
job done fortunately is there anything
that like is on the horizon in terms of
like medical science that you're looking
at in terms you've being able to fix
your eyes uh not that I know of
I spoke to doctors about it you know
because IIIi was yeah I was always
curious what what what could be done but
I don't think in my lifetime there is
but the reason I'm retired was at the
Gastelum fire because I was cleared to
fight and the doctors were always like
we don't really advise it but you are
cleared you've passed the test just by
the skin of your teeth and for me that
was all well and good you got do you
medical the most stressful part of all
of that was when you you could have got
do a full training camp now then fly
somewhere and you're gonna see another
doctor a commission Docs right the way
in right and you don't know what this
doctors gonna be like you don't know if
he knows anything about eyes you don't
know if he wants to be a hero you don't
know if he wants to make [ __ ] press
the guy that pulled the main event do
you know what I mean yeah very very
stressful time so for me the fight was
always the easy part the hard part was
just [ __ ] making it to the Octagon and
I got to the weigh-ins and I get cleared
up the feeling was okay we're good the
fights on cuz I didn't know the fight
was on and said I got past the
Commission doctor how many different
fights did you have to go through it
about he's about 12 something like
fights with that I'm not sure he's 12
something like that oh damn
belcheck calmly now Belcher Tim Kennedy
Kong Lee Rockhold CB tells lies Anderson
Silva Luke Rockhold Dan Henderson GSP
Gastelum 11:11 yeah